Joe Kraus came to speak at Wycominator.
He was the previous founder of Xsite,
an old search engine company.
And then eventually he did his own
new start called JotSpot at the time,
which was this freemium
software-as-a-service wiki company.
And they had set up pricing and
in his talk at YC, it just made sense.
It was like, oh, we thought about
pricing where the top end tier of
the pricing would be stuff that
people didn't need to get.
Permission from legal or financial or
get a special document or
review done, that people can just
pay it on the corporate credit card.
$200 a month, he said.
It seems to be what the limits are for
that.
And then we step down the features
based on the usage, downwards.
And then we always knew we
wanted to have a freemium plan.
Or a free plan that people can try
out the service because we felt like
our user experience was going
to be what sells a lot of
what sells a lot of what Wufoo does.
Although I think completely
different about that now when
I advise companies about going freemium.
But that's how it started,
it's just starting with his price and
that made sense and
then we figured out the tiers.
Where it was going to be the cutoff for
the functionality,
just based on looking
at our competitors.
Here's what they do,
can we be more generous?
Do we have a guess on what's going to
me us different or what have you?
And I think one of the best things that
we did is we offered plans that offered
unlimited forms.
Because it was this idea, you get
them hooked into this idea that you
can use forms for
anything and everything.
And yes,
everyone's going to come in on one
vertical or one very specific use case.
But if you have the idea,
it's like oh, there's an unlimited
resource of these things.
Which it kind of truly is, because the
marginal cost of building another form,
allowing people to make another one,
costs us nothing.
And so it's easy to be generous on that.
But what we want to do is hook them in,
where now everyone in the organization
using Wufoo for
all different kinds of uses cases.
And then they start thinking about
problem solving in the Wufoo ways,
like I can use Wufoo for this, I can
do this for this, or do this for this.
And then that's what makes a
subscription business do really well is
that when people start relying you on in
a long term relationship sort of way.
It's like this is a long
term solution for
lots of different
problems in the company.
I think what's tricky is Wufoo's one
of those generalized products where it
could be used for
lots of different stuff.
We had every industry,
market or vertical using Wufoo.
And that is because forms is the first
step of interaction of collecting data,
interacting with people.
Creativity was always
our biggest problem.
People not knowing
what do I do with this.
It sounds neat but how do I utilize it?
So we spent a lot of time
on education to get people
get hooked on in their first use case,
so
that way they'll eventually
learn the other ways to use it.